he means so much to me that it's I'm
proud of myself that I didn't cry when I
told the story about the cardboard box
in London I almost did yeah and your
answer when I asked you what makes you
emotional was anything related to
Parenting yeah if you guys have ever
seen or go see the song Papa by the
Belgian musician stromi it's basically
this it was a hit single in France and
Belgium and there's a great music video
for it of this guy who's basically being
a bad dad and when he and I watch that
video together I always
cry yeah you're kind of tearing up right
now yeah yeah wow yeah it's serious
which is new in my experience of Derek
cus like seeing this why do you think
that is it's so important the stakes
are wellow yeah
wow yeah new
experience got to collect myself for a
second it's the stakes are so high that
it's like if you do this right it passes
on wow holy
we're not any Rush Zero
Rush hm it's funny also collecting my
thoughts on how to say this I don't have
to explain it much nobody's asked
directly it's like if you do this right
it passes on for many generations like a
kid that's raised
really well can like past
that generosity of spirit you
know o and then somebody that's raised
like ignored might pass on that like
scarcity of spirit you know
mhm holy I'm not doing this for the
media this is not like trying to be a
Captured Moment holy
yeah there we
go yeah thank you for answering ing that
this is new also I'll say for folks what
a gift that you have something that you
respond this way too though it's kind of
the only thing I do you know it's
funny my ex after we broke up said like
wow I've known you for so many years
like I've never seen you get mad I've
never seen you cry like I've never even
really seen you get upset like yeah I
just don't really like I'm a happy dude
and yeah like this is the only thing but
it's like it's not a it's not a
obviously like not an upset cry it's
like holy this is such a big
deal
yeah